the trump era is also going to be one of
the weirder times when when people look
back historically about the division in
this country
he's such a polarizing figure that so
many people
felt like
they could abandon
their own ethics and morals and
principles
just to
attack
him and anybody who supports him
because he is an existential threat to
democracy itself but don't you think
it's not a cause but maybe like a
symptom like it's gonna get you said it
got real weird maybe it's gonna get
weirder yeah i think it's gonna get
weirder he's gonna run again do you
think he's going to get well he's
running against a dead man you know i
mean biden
shakes hands with people that aren't
even there when he gets off stage yeah i
think he's seeing ghosts yeah you see
him on jimmy kimmel the other day no
well he was just rambling i mean he's if
he was
anyone else
if he was a republican if that was
donald trump doing that
every
[ __ ] talk show would be screaming for
him to be off the air and by the way i'm
not a trump supporter in any way shape
or form i've had the opportunity to have
him on my show more than once i've said
no every time i don't want to help him
i'm not interested in helping him the
the night is still young we'll see
if i have month tonight is still young
yeah i think i'll have them on i think
you'll have them on really why do you
think that because you'll have putin on
[Laughter]
and you're competitive as [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
i i think
ultimately um i mean you had you've had
a lot of people that i think you might
you may otherwise be skeptical would i
have a good conversation which i think
is your metric you don't care about
politics so can i have a good
conversation and i think you had
uh like people people like kanye on for
example and you had a great conversation
with them i think you
i think uh yeah but kanye is an artist
like but kanye doing well or not doing
well doesn't change the course of our
country
yeah but you know
do you really
bear the responsibility of the course of
our country based on a conversation i
think you can
revitalize and rehabilitate someone's
image
in a way that is pretty shocking look at
the way people look at alex jones now
because alex jones has been on my
podcast a few times yeah how do they
which direction the people that have
watched those podcasts think he's
hilarious and they think that he
definitely [ __ ] up with that whole
sandy hook thing
um but
he's right more than he's wrong
and
he's not an evil guy he's just a guy
who's
had some psychotic breaks in his life
he's had some genuine mental health
issues that he's addressed he's had some
serious bouts of alcoholism some serious
bouts of you know substance abuse and
they've contributed to some very poor
thinking
but if you know the guy if you get to
know him like i have i've known him for
more than 20 years and if you know him
on podcasts you realize like
he is genuinely trying to unearth some
things that are genuinely disturbing for
most people like is the guy that was
telling me about
epstein's uh island
[ __ ] decade ago
at least he was telling me about i was
like what
you're telling me there's a place
where they bring elites
to compromise them with underage girls
and they film them really like what cut
the [ __ ] out of here like no president
clinton's been there everyone's been
there like but it sounds like nonsense
and not only is it true but people keep
getting [ __ ] murdered for it did you
see that latest clinton advisor that got
murdered about it yep yeah hung with an
extension cord shot himself in the chest
30 miles from his house and they're
calling it a suicide and now even elon
musk is asking where's the clientele
list yeah we should we should probably
see who's been to that island yeah we
should probably see who's been to that
island
and there's probably more of those kind
of things out there that haven't been
exposed
yeah but sort of
uh to push back
in you you had those conversations with
alex jones wouldn't you be able to have
the same kind of conversation with
donald trump what's the problem reveal
no it's not the problem you revealed
that alex jones is a human being he's
[ __ ] up he has demons in his head he's
obviously chaotic all over the place but
there's some
uh wisdom to the perspective he takes on
the world even if though he is often
full of [ __ ] he is able to predict
certain things and very few people are
willing to bring up so isn't trump the
same way [ __ ] up person egomaniac
uh whatever personality things you can
talk about isn't it worthwhile to lay it
out like who's going to if you listen to
interviews of trump
who has the balls to call him out on
this [ __ ] chris wallace did
yeah no calling out somebody on their
[ __ ] is easy when you're just being
adversarial but as a person who is
genuinely empathetically trying to
understand yeah i think you're really
good at that like you pulled up i don't
know if he would genuinely be there
you know what i'm saying like i think he
would be putting on a performance and
that's i think he can break through that
in like 30 minutes i'd need more time
than that
and he doesn't do any
you can drugs
alex hi yeah get him drunk and he'll
start talking about interdimensional
child molesters yeah you know and then
you you get the real alex or maybe maybe
you have somebody else on as well to
introduce chaos like alex
no no no no no
i would have to be just me and him i
would have to that would be a focused
thing i would have to like really
take time with with trump but also i'm
not um well versed enough politically to
know
all of the corruption that's been
alleged and to understand
what the the whole russia gate stuff
what what's real like how much of it
it's clear
that there is more than one organization
that's involved in communicating with
russia
before the 2016 election so it's pretty
clear that the clinton administration
was involved
it's pretty clear that the trump
administration had some communication
with some people in russia it's pretty
clear that hunter biden had some very
suspicious dealings in ukraine and
there's a lot going on there man and
it's it's hard for anybody to parse
it's really hard for anybody and
especially to have an objective
assessment
of
exactly what's going on and then to be
able to do that and broadcast it
publicly that's quite a project and i
think
if you really want to do that correctly
it's something that i would have to
research for a long time and to really
really and i don't have that kind of
time not not for maybe for certain
for certain people that you're really
curious about like you have that kind of
time for bob lazar yes
yes
but maybe not for donald trump
you